- Ciroc...one...
- One, two...one...
- [Together] One, two,
three, Ciroc, Ciroc, Ciroc!
- Hey!
- Let's get some pussy!
- You've been everywhere,
have you met Puff Daddy?
- Puffy, Puff Daddy, P. Diddy,
yes, I've met all of them.
- He also has a vodka, Ciroc.
- He does, I heard about it.
- Do you think, if we gave you two vodkas,
you could tell which one is Ciroc?
- For sure, 'cause I'm
a vodka connoisseur.
- I am a good judge of vodka.
- Oh, I'll be able to tell.
- You think you can tell
the difference?
- I think I can tell.
- You down to do a shot?
- Absolutely.
- I usually hit the table, then, bing.
- Cheers, and then you have
to, like, put it on the ground.
- Old school would be
"holler and swaller."
- Holler, what?
- Ahh!
- Bang!
- Boom, Jason Derulo!
(laughing)
- That wasn't strange at all.
- I nailed it, right?
(coughing)
- What do we think?
- Well, we need to taste
the other one first.
- (coughing)
- What was that?
- Was that one not good?
- I just wanna taste the other one first.
- Okay, all right, all right!
- Do you think this tastes like
what Puff Daddy might taste like?
- Do you mean what you're saying?
- That's definitely not Ciroc.
- (still coughing)
- You know it, you don't
need to taste the other one?
- I'll taste the other one.
- This dude's trying to get
me turned up right here!
- I think I'm getting myself
turned up, and no one else.
- I've been doing a bunch of these and
I'm starting to get a little loopy.
- Well, that's good, that's good.
- You are so drunk right
now, this is hilarious.
- What are we doing, what's up?
- You know what, I'm proud of you.
- Salud!
- Waller!
(yelping noises)
- [Both] There we go, cheers!
- Jason Derulo!
- Ooh.
- That's got to be Puff Daddy's.
- Yeah, how come?
- I think it has more
percentage of alcohol.
- Tastes sweet, smooth, earthy, herby...
- It has a hint of sweetness.
- Kind of like Puff Daddy.
- All right.
- So, between the two,
which one is more Daddy?
- This one.
- You are correct.
- Oh, how do you like them apples?
- Well, it's vodka, not apples.
- Well, you know...
- You are correct.
- (laughs)
- Yeah, I do this.
- Do you think he would make
anything he touches taste better?
- I do believe so, I believe
he has a Midas touch.
- All right, Puff Daddy,
may I call you Daddy?
- Yeah, yes, you can call me Daddy.
Okay, son.
- (laughs)
I know that you know
the difference between
your vodka and other vodkas,
so I'm just gonna ask you,
can we take a shot together?
- We can definitely take a shot together.
On the count of three, we
say, "Ciroc, Ciroc, Ciroc,
"Let's get some pussy!"
So smooth.
- I don't know what this is, what is this?
- It's some more things to
get you to have a good time
and loosen up in Vegas.
- Is this more vodka?
This is beautiful!
Daddy, thank you so much.
- Let's go, to you, son.
- To you, father, cheers.
- Yes, cheers.
- That is good.
- So good.
- And I wanna thank you
guys for being such an
inspiration to REVOLT.
- Am I an inspiration to you?!
- Yes, because what we
look for in our talent
is authenticity, and I believe
you are who you are, son.
- This is the greatest moment of my life.
- Oh, and can I, um, never mind.